a esta hora sigue la búsqueda de
personas que quedaron bajo los escombros
de esa edificación de nueve pisos en la
población de Umán que fue atacada esta
mañana con uno de los misiles de los 23
misiles lanzados por bombarderos rusos
desde la proximidades del mar caspio
este este impacto en esta edificación de
la ciudad de Umán fue el que tuvo
mayores consecuencias humanas esta
mañana dicen las autoridades que allí
vivían más de 100 personas 46
apartamentos
23 de ellos quedaron prácticamente
destruidos y dicen que el número de
personas sigue fallecidas sigue
aumentando con las obras entre ellos
niños Esta es una población muy
importante primero porque es un lugar de
peregrinaje para miles y miles de judíos
que siguen esa rama del judaísmo
jasídico vienen aquí a celebrar el fin
del año judío
vienen junto a la tumba de su creador
del rabino nashman de breslov y allí
cada año Incluso el año pasado cuando ya
estaba la guerra llegaron al menos
10.000 judíos también es una ciudad
importante porque miles y miles de
ucranianos se desplazaron allí buscando
Refugio desde el comienzo de esta
invasión muchos de ellos aseguran que si
bien no sentían los ataques y eran
testigos de cómo los misiles que eran
lanzados desde el mar Negro
acusaban la ciudad cuando iban
especialmente camino hacia quieto Así
que siguen a esta ahora buscando
personas bajo estos escombros en un
ataque que tiene conmocionado nuevamente
a Ucrania y a la espera de lo que pueda
pasar esta noche porque como dicen las
autoridades Podrían haber más ataques en
las próximas horas